the topic of
personalization in fashion that's it
that's simply the future the
question now is how to solve that and i
think our approach is one
that is very promising and you can be a
part of the future fashion
experience today in the podcast or here
julia
busch is a guest on the youtube podcast channel she is the founder of
outfits 300 million in sales
recently profitable an exciting story of
growth above all
a founding by a woman from 0
employees to now 350 let
's go with
young people it can't be true
how long  I've been following you and
we've never really
spoken in person for a long time I've
just turned up in our office until now, of course, we've
finally agreed on an
equally overdue podcast from a company
that has had to crooner the German
start-up landscape for many years now
one thinks i say the
guest is julia busch from austria
is a delusional started with or are
you lucky we started in
1012 did you or did you miss it because
others have already done everything exactly that
was my first job and my entry into
the scene so to speak and I was allowed to
do my startup MBA and
then  we have and you are whether
the werler i am originally the
voters exactly but never found it that
exciting but did
my internship as a student in
a startup on lake constance, which is very
rare there and i caught fire
and knew that i would do it
myself at some point  want to do and
then I came to berlin with the
idea of founding my own that was s
ill being tested exactly mega earlier was o
e year old and i was
given a lot of responsibility i was a
lowed to manage the internationalization and a
d then but still had to get out of it
I was there for exactly two years and
then I'm really fast-forwarding
through the different phases
I
was also allowed to go there under 1 of a company, so when I arrived
I think I was 40 people and
when they decided to leave after two years
, we were 1500
accordingly, I definitely
lost any fear of speed
there, I was mega  I was able to build up a network
and he was just totally
grateful for how much freedom and
trust was given.
You looked up what could
be done in the fashion sector and then
saw the Austria cd. Exactly, we have my
co-founder, Anna, and I saw
that  Of course, online shopping
professionally explodes, but
at the same time, many customers were simply
overwhelmed by the huge
selection, which of course increases even further through online
shopping, and that
I think everyone wants to feel comfortable
in their own skin and most of them
also want to look good, but many say
I know  not at all where to
start it's totally exhausting  Enough
to find the right thing for me
and then the idea came up,
what if we actually turned the shopping
experience for fashion mai completely
upside down and
didn’t start with the range
but really with the customer and
personalize the hyper  ok and gave the
situation leads but that worries
only observed
that was didier the real kik and the
real inspiration came from new york
were then there together with a friend
and he made a
personal shopper what the usa
much more  people do it like
here, it costs about 100 dollars an hour
and then you have an expert who
puts things together individually for you and of course walks you through the shops with your skin, so to speak, the
lean respect and a
pre-selection for you there  based on his
profile, so to speak, of your body
according to your colors and that's what your friend
did there and that too  an
entrepreneur and found shopping totally stupid in
principle but was
completely enthusiastic about this experience and had
a lot of
bags in our hands and a big smile on our face and
then we thought this is such a great
experience that we would actually
like to make available to everyone  and
offer it online for free and that
was the way the starting shot was fired like ok
and then
you looked for something that just works somehow investors
and then came up with a company for
Islam and then it started
exactly then it started we then have
our jobs our  essen jobs
and we already knew that we
want to make the whole thing big, so we
also brought investors on board and
edged spare the first investors that
is also i think a great tip that
i would give to anyone who wants to start a business or
is looking for investors, so to speak, of
this network  to set it up before
you need it one
thing was the would have founder i had me  did an
internship and the other thing was
the
general meeting of the holtzbrinck ventures,
which were also invested at zalando
and we knew about them, yes, and
accordingly we started the
machine right away, but back then it was just the
time to take in 23 million
and not directly how  today 20 or so
exactly when i
see the rounds today i think the rolls were too small
but back then it was okay that
was how you got there
anyway powerpoint presentation of the idea and
then said hey here this is our idea
company reviews now in  media instead of
that anyway I assume now there
weren’t eight or nine or
ten million back then there are always two
gets a few percentages so that was
ok you can now put the money in and
then you built the website like that
and it’s online  or built up this
team but in gdansk also quite a lot
i mainly have a stylist
who then give
advice and i had to  yes
then would be do i had to
have the goods somehow you would have to have the
team somehow or
sit up this process once i there now as a
man the is aimed at men still to
my ear all yes exactly have actually
just learned outfit as for women
accordingly  now also
proceed ok ok so that's important
but it was many years old and
I heard it that way, I
registered
I ask for something to be filled out and
then I also called colleagues from
them and then you can therefore get the
goods, so to speak  i
choose something and then return what i don't
like is that in the end it was
more complicated, so
it's a very personalized process, so to speak,
in any case that means we
want to understand you very precisely and to
understand a style profile
very well  ie which colors
maxi like which colors suit you also
which style do you like which brands which
it's not possible there is somehow wool
that scratches you so we understand all
this and we understand not only the
first time you
fill out our questionnaire but also over time
and we then convert that into
personal recommendations for you and
we started with that  we
basically made an outfit surprise box from your
stylist, so to speak, and we've
expanded that significantly in the meantime, that
means our customers can now if you
have that event somehow and
you really need the complete outfit,
then you can get it from us, but
also if you say so  i just need
new polo shirts now you can see
all the polo shirts in outfit rehab that fit
to you philipp on the basis of all the information
we've collected because i've collected them
and that's exactly what women can do now as well as
men but that's why I
describe the process again  for you
my that's the customer crisis
but then they're out the back  to fulfill that, so
to speak, you also get a
lot of returns, logically, send them in
the box after philipp previously left
the polo shirts, I always only get 12,
then three automatically come back, it’s
really annoying, so the process for us works in the end, like the 1 in the
heart  the whole thing is
personalization and the question now is
how can i present personalization in a
scalable form and our
answer to this is a combination of
the human
service of our
experts, i.e. it is our stylists and our
algorithms, which of course have gotten
better and better over time and also
more and more able to support the stylist
, that means when you have completed the first questionnaire with us,
the algorithm in the system will suggest
what are the parts and what are the
outfits that have the highest
probability of keeping with philipp and
the stylist then has the power  again
the human curation and selection  ahl
on it and that makes the
whole thing scalable in the end and we can
see that the
more customers use our system, the better the
system has become, so we see, for
example, the turnover per customer increases
over time but also for you as a customer
all the more often  there petri uses the
more knowledge about you and the better the
recommendation is that you
can build up a personal relationship with
the stylist or is it still
technical in the end and so don't look for me
somehow everything is different
philipp thinks here because it's half there
year raved about this blue polo shirt
i have some again or
so it is not like that but that can
definitely be the case so of
course it depends entirely on the customer
there are customers who want these personal
relationships then they get
them from us and then  there are customers who
prefer to simply interact with their outfit web
and order something that works
as well as they know how  many people
but we are 350 employees in a team
all around what can
you say i would say around 100 ok so
and that is after the
rectors already or with or front
tour of course after goals but well i
mean that that  now at the beginning
everyone who was looking at it
noticed that it was
kind of, well maybe it was
already that we have to do to get her
down but you are a built model, so to speak,
so that's where
I think I am but that  if i have
another box like that i get a guilty
conscience not to take everything because i
then know the model i know so much
back but they have so
much skill to do it today so our
our model is of course based on the fact
that we make a pre-selection for you
and then you can either
give feedback online or
next to it if it's in your bedroom at home
and you've tried it on
and are interested in us e  ben not only
returns the nerves or the costs
but these are mainly data points
because everything you try on is of
course totally significant for us how
you found it is so the wool of
this sweater was too scratchy the style
of this shirt the pattern was me  but
a bit too unusual all of these
data points are of course received by us
and are four more significant white
now data points that
we get from an online questionnaire, for example,
so they are actually very valuable for our tours
also okay okay that of
course not so much  you do
n't have to tell yourself hurt but after that i
also gave away two things in the office
i can definitely put them
back and then i gave them to
my colleagues but i'm very nice
but the model is still
more difficult than the current
model where customers tend to  wise
keep everything at that time
beauty products or something that
are not normally returned
yes that one  part of the model at mode
because people want to try it on
want to see it for themselves so far it's
just been a hurry and what is the
much more important metric for us is
actually how much share of
wallet we have, so if the customer
looks at it, so to speak, how much  do i spend a
year on fashion or how many
items do i buy what percentage of that
goes to audrey and we also have a
large proportion of our customers who use it as a
subscription model,
so to speak, you don’t have to but
you can and with them to  example is
50 percent of your fashion week goes to ob
petry which is quite a lot and of
course that also means that we can make even better
recommendations because
then we can also build on your wardrobe
we can then not
just say we say that we every time  now
an outfit that goes great together
but we can also say this about
the jeans you bought six months ago
Does the sweater and this shirt go really
well with it or have
you ever thought about combining this coat with
the service but you buy
donate from you that means you
don't buy from the companies themselves but that
's points in it from adidas or
lacoste or something  it's always the right place to buy
from you now you ask yourself the
nasty questions i'd say for
entrepreneurs and can you think about
how to do what you would want to do
then you could say we
now suggest or send things to our customers
the things that we can get
particularly cheaply or more
cleverly than others because you
have a higher margin on them, so if you
say, for example, somehow we
now have people, last season's
somehow worn out cheaply at adidas
but the current one is nicely installed
that part  give the customer moderate processing
, then we have a higher margin
than if I now do the current hot
thing where I myself n  of course you
have already suggested to the customer
you already have certain
influence possibilities you
could do that but that would certainly
not maximize the customer lifetime value
and that is ultimately
our game so our business
works totally through loyalty
overlooked high customer lifetime value
and accordingly that beats it  always
any other logic that we have,
so it's even different, that we look very
closely and say how can
we be very flexible, so to
speak, so our cooperation with the brands is so that
if we don't sell something
then we can  also give it back
or exchange it or whatever so
we are very flexible and
accordingly we don't have the pressure and
where do the customers come from than you
have probably changed a lot like now in ten
years, that's how it was at the
beginning but still  no
one really tries to get advice now in fashion
in that
sense, it also comes very strongly from
recommendations and more than 70 percent of
our business are existing customers who
have been buying from us for years, so to speak, and
then it is actually a lot of push
marketing, i would say
social media marketing tv is also
interesting for us  aren't the visitors like
that i've always been in business for so long
what has grown over search
isn't not so possible for you
in the same sense as this classic
i have a very specific product in
mind and look for it on google nearby that
it is now  not the match for us,
but we just come completely about
the topic of inspiration
and discovery and accordingly also
about other channels and that's
just so incredibly exciting for us now
because the
extremely accelerated
online penetration in the fashion sector,
also accelerated by the pandemic,
is of course the topic
inspiration much more in the center
so it has sic  h
yes, the online share in
fashion retail has increased from 20 to 30 percent and will increase
to 50 percent over the next few years
and accordingly,
on the customer side, it is no longer just about the
items that i know that i want to have
as cheaply as possible and
to order online as quickly as possible, but there
are also a lot of customers
who say i
don't really know exactly what i'm looking for, but
i have an event or i
just want to go back to the office now and
want to get to know something new and they'll
come  then to us and it's still
wouldn't it be an obvious
intermediate step to say and before you
send the outfits to days
you first send the recipient what would be in the
box very good
idea we'll do that too I'll do that but won't
I  we didn't do it from the
beginning that's one of the things we've
taken with us over time so
if actually that  the model is
quite fanned out and the customer is
now given a lot more options and more
flexibility to also take part in this
process of recommendation, so to speak.
That means you as a
customer get a kind of online preview before we send your expansion
home to
you and then you can do it again there
say was the part that
no that didn’t need to be sent
to me that i would like to exchange or i thought of
something else you still
seemed to pack somehow or okay okay and were
there any
so if you hear it like that it
should actually have grown up with
influenza market remembered the ten years
are also in the last ten years
characterized by influenza marketing are
there any men or now
women who have strongly
driven this type of feature
testimonial interestingly enough so far there
has not been any influence on the men’s side
for us  such a huge topic but
now with the launch of  upstream
women's fashion will of course be very, very
large but there is only 1
there are men influenza but our
customer people not necessarily these men
in Flanders who change the fashion in
oh yes and but also find others in
plants if any now
in the following  maybe just follow frank
theelen but i mean the follower a lot of
people maybe somehow
from the scene of those who are not
so fashion savvy yes it's a
topic but now compared to the
other channels we don't have a
huge one  but maybe you still have
ideas so that means the show is big
and otherwise the classic social
media is big
the recommendation
vibrated so there are discount codes
or exactly there is now
another recommendation program for existing customers
whereby we will see so will soak,
so to speak  customer via
recommendation regardless of whether he came through
the intensified program or  he
doesn't and we see that even more
customers come without the incentive
so it's really that people found it
good and recommended it to others
even without the staging that's the
main topic ok and tell me salander
started doing something similar
so there are numbers  that
got on my nerves but then old
colleagues then say let's
do it myself so i have a
very good relationship with the founders and of course
if a new player like this comes onto the
market then it's more likely
to strike first and look at it in the end
But that helped us a lot because our
main challenge is still to make
this model of personal shopping
online known at all and to make it
big in Europe, so if you look
in the USA then it's
really a big model there where,
say the companies, there is  are noted
or which tricks, for example,
make more than two billion in sales
that means there are effective  lich the
consumer is already awakened in this model rhine
and accordingly in
europe the topic is still to be made
known and just
to convince many customers that
try and that is there was
another
market companion so about the poverty
any you have with you  who noticed
exactly exactly what we had in the end is
was also totally exciting because we started out
at the same time with the same topic
in the same city with the
same vision and the same
target group and accordingly it made a lot of sense
for us to do something together at some
point and in  2009
10 it was time and then
we brought the two teams, the
two
bands and customer base together
, so to speak, are you actually now kona winners
or losers because I mean on the
one hand if you can’t really
go out anymore and then what should you
do  can also be styled funny when he
sits on the sofa with a sei  te e
commerce boys what we do for you more
so i would say in the short term it
was definitely a challenge for
exactly the reasons
you mentioned when the people are at home
don't go to the office have completely different
demands so it was a
challenging but  also as an
entrepreneur very exciting time i
find uncertainty cool and then you can
somehow rethink things in the
long term or in the medium term of
course it really helps us that
the online trend in the fashion sector is now
much higher and we will see that
over the last few months  that
gives
you a real boost you've also raised quite a
lot of money by now, let's say, she
wants the first financing the
financing the first
financing back then 50
60 million rhein have flowed in the meantime did
you expect that from needing so much money
is a good question so  I'll put it this way,
we definitely have a very
big vision g  estarted and
accordingly it was already clear that
we need a lot of funds and resources
yes but is now through so rich
yourself or something the new round again
we have just delivered our first
profitable quarter so
want to grow now thank you it
will stay that way so there is  that means
financing somehow 0 even if it is
necessary if it offers and how you
now okay okay and
your co-founder yes yes that is
unfortunately forced to be done but
at some point rossi came out because exactly came out as
operational in 2008 but is
still on the board
so  you will do that for yourself country manager he
so to speak yes i am of course not
alone i have a very, very great team
but we are sitting
so you say it was always like that you two
i have always said all the photos showed
up why did you have to have the
two funds for the more how  In the end it came
about, so to speak, I think I'm
convinced on this journey as a founder
, you have to be in the
I still have to check for myself I'm
still that's where I want to invest my lifetime,
so to speak, and am I
still the right one so that's the
right phase for me and for me
personally it's so I
find this journey from female founders to
tough and i have the feeling i have
a new job and a new
challenge every year that i can grow on
and for others it was different at some point
they had the feeling the company is
really big now and we have a great
team but i would actually like to
i'm dreaming about the early
phases again and that's actually what
i really enjoyed and where i had
the feeling i'd have a big
impact and accordingly she
decided at some point that of
course it's not an easy
decision if it's your own, so to speak
baby has grown so big that it
actually no longer
corresponds to the phase that you are passionate about
and that he  I have the utmost respect
that she made this decision to
go out operationally and has
now founded another super great company with planet
, for which she has the
greatest passion, ok, that
means let's all encourage
ourselves, our topic is
women, so to speak, female founders  there are
n't that many but it was
n't that particularly problematic for you now how does that sound like
it somehow of
course ended with them
then i probably made
it somehow on the people well
i probably know that next to the family and stuff
like that  it's already the case that many people who are
now on easy-to-use ok
blatantly there is such a hack or
often so that you can also say the
state is facing bankruptcy that
you can do well in the house or my
husband is
independent anyway  with you everything sounds very much like
do it after do it well
i come from a family of
entrepreneurs
so my grandfather has ma  n
somehow produces ski poles but
otherwise not at all i grew up
but with the belief that my
parents gave me that if i
believe in something and want something that i
can do it and i think
that shaped me a lot and then i
just  at some point I caught fire for this
entrepreneurship when I just
saw that and
then I set my mind to it and I think the
important thing is to just go step by step
and not
immediately imagine the next ten years
and all the challenges that will come
your way  but
really to say okay, so to speak, to
box and to say how long I give
myself for the start-up
maybe it's only three months at first or
maybe it's three weekends or
a year and then to see what
happens and what I've experienced  is
that we just naturally in the
first year of the company's foundation we had
no idea what we were  ren super naive and there
are every day every week
we had challenges that we
had never encountered before and
then we just
looked vienna we can ask a lot for help
and then just one
boulder after the other out of the
cleared away and by overcoming the
challenges you just build up
a legal awareness that no matter what
happens there will somehow be a
solution and accordingly I can only
encourage everyone if you have such a
lifelong dream to jump in
and try it out and
then just step up, so to speak
step by step you have to solve the challenges that
are sure to come and it
's a really big roller coaster and in
retrospect it all sounds somehow
logical and maybe it's just
that it's not of course when you
're in it what was it the cliff so it used
to be like that  do you have in the market
you could read a bit listen to times where
so very difficult  rig had to be
financed when you weren't yet
profitable these are the hardest times but
or what do you think is his he's
honestly difficult to say what
the very hardest times were now
i think the time with the greatest
uncertainty was actually
around march april  last year but not only
for us but for many it just was
n't where is it what happened and where we
also expected okay if now
because i don't if the camp goes on the
walk down how long will we survive
that our things and if you are through
that  then not so much
can happen i would say because then
you can always put it into perspective with the
times in which you asked yourself really
existential questions up to
now it was actually a
role that you could have
expected a little bit on the teacher
knows you yourself even better than
going face-to-face now with
ali and basically made this company your
person
I have the feeling that you are part of
the start-up scene, so to speak,
but you have never done this
jessica alba job. Okay, I'm
on some juries here now and
I'm also the woman here in the company with
so many hundreds
you could have made people build, but you don't have
to be so interested in owning it
, so i think it
's a personality question, i'm
very, very focused on outfit rhi and,
so to speak, on the management of this team
even more than now
on the external positioning and it
's what i'm doing
more and more and opening myself up more and
investing more because i would just like
to encourage other people and especially other women
to live their dreams and that's how it
is for me  a motivation
to share more and for me, for
example, when I compare it, a
network like linkedin is very v  much more
natural than instagram we may have to
be there i'm much faster following
i think around 30,000 but i mean
kukksi was
800,000
but they say you're already
thinking about doing more now yes
absolutely we just
saw again that
he makes a lot of masks  again that with tesla is
amazing getting there
alone he is the pr show
already strong but i didn't have to have the
investors go there either people
urged how do you do
a bit more
on the tube or something like
that they rarely do that to me
to get somewhere okay okay
be made back then for 2012 based is
already with leading seven
hours
long and which ones are the biggest
we started in germany
accordingly that's the biggest
market for us but it's about 60 percent
and 40 percent
international  business france, for
example, is a market that is
growing very, very quickly for us and works very
well  otherwise we are in the benelux and
scandinavia
and the markets are so similar so the
men especially there so
honest in approach yes yes and no i would say
that it can be known berlin style you can tell
the german statistics exactly
what a dutch wearer says or
so for the dutch customers
we have dutch stylists who
live in gdansk and for the swedish customers we
have swedish stylists and
the markets are the same in that
the medical staff had to make me feel good i
want to look good but
i would like a service that supports me
inspiration  it
works the same everywhere but of
course the fashion tastes
are different so the
swedes actually wear mainly
dark blue gray and black while the
dutch people also like to think about the color fit in the
place
we've seen big differences
there are always big differences here because countries are
particularly profitable especially
going strong okay that is  a bit like the
usa
so in the end clearly the germans
like it because we just have such a large
customer base it is of course
the most profitable for sure and
what is a usa even that's it fix
somehow like you said two
billion sales are the gallery
exchange value they are i think 5 drives at the
moment anyway two half in the forest apple
what is a normal one they always say
us shops are
logically larger than german but
it is already 20 times larger than you
why is it like that yes i think it is
american consumers are just
more open to
trying out new things
and correspondingly to enter into such a new
model is certainly a
different
willingness to try it out and
at the same time the
personal shopping model of service and
convenience is even bigger than it is in the usa
in europe so far and
i think we're
just a little bit different in time  t and afterwards
i assume that in europe
it will be accepted in the same way forward
as it can be seen there and the
topic of
personalization in fashion that's
so it's just the future the
question now is how to solve it and me
think our approach is one that is
very promising and can be a
part of the future fashion
experience the parts that say the most
sells and the message stays with the
people so we then
choose which adidas shoes or white t-shirts from
because i prefer it  or what what what
are like you the super items so we
are actually very good
at recommending pants and jeans because that
's often the case that you somehow don't
know exactly which size which model
which fits well and we sell
a lot of that now  times to
highlight the category because the advice
regarding fit works particularly well
he becomes this partner on the
supplier side is then namely li  so boar
is
ok and now you even talked about one
now planet that also makes the
macs in the podcast
so you can obviously do something that is so sustainability-
oriented
what fashion is that okay what
you actually do today somehow we
send boxes around the world  and even more
clothes and actually you
have to reduce it or find a way
altogether yes i think that the biggest
problem with fashion is the
fast pace of life that means a part that is
bought is contributed on average seven
that now not whether petry
but more generally so to speak  market
seven times that's
terrible and
accordingly, as i look at it,
we simply have
a huge lever to make a difference in the fashion industry
and we're working with
audrey to ensure that customers no
longer buy something new every month and
that's somehow 34 times  put it on
and then throw it away or have a
corpse lying in the closet
our aim is to find the part for
you that will become your new favorite part
, what you wear until you can no longer
, so to speak, and we focus
very strongly on a very large
focus on sustainable brands in the
portfolio
as well as angels, for example, i think so
and so  we
see a lot that customers
want to buy much more sustainably and want to
build up a sustainable wardrobe
but don't know how so
which brand can i trust now
what does organic cotton mean, what do i have to
pay attention to and we can help the customer as
consultants  stand aside and
really say how do i build
a sustainable wardrobe now and
accordingly yes it is a
very important topic for us another aspect of
it we are also currently testing is
to go there and say if i
look at a wardrobe and have it  you
determine a lot of parts in the closet that you
just don't wear anymore so
how can we do this now  sharing
gives a second life back
to the point how how do we extend the
life of fashion items
and we did the first test
, for example, that we
simply deliver a bag with every outfit box, so to speak
, where you can put things that you no longer use
you can simply pack things
in and send them to us quite comfortably, so to speak, without barriers
via your your return
in the end and we have seen that
almost 20 percent of the customers have used
this and
things are given a second life, things that are not
exactly precise could be something  so it can
be something from us but if you
donated it and now we're
just checking that a model like that what we now how
can we find other models
find incentives like spiders it will
continue to really get a
security in our model
on
when it comes to economic success, the end is the really big question, how do
you manage the word is probable  ch
last year you heard the most when
you but the business model late
costs namely only how durable how
long do people stay with you and
what does it cost to buy them is the
classic thing you always have with many
the commerce film but i'm
through now  very extreme and yes also with
the subscriptions you can see how long
people stay how much do they buy
how much do you return that you
actually put the whole model on the
internet absolutely precisely so that
’s the most important thing for us too being
focused all the time, so to speak
how are the cohorts developing and what
we see that our cohorts are getting
better every year, for example
last year the turnover per
customer increased by eleven percent compared to the
previous year from foreign water from water
is i can’t say that exactly, that’s an
order of magnitude of over  100 euros already
so the share of wallet, so to speak,
our customers is between 30 and 50
percent wa  rtet in any case porn
is what's up ten percent
so that we've
improved our algorithms that means
the recommendation quality has
improved so to speak and the second thing is that we
now give customers more options
to shop with us that means you
can either  have the stylist
put together a selection for you or
you can now see what we call
your job in your outfit rhi app
what are the pieces that match what i have already
bought or what are the
top 5 jeans dimitri based on
everything they have  know me recommends and
that leads to the fact that the customers
buy a lot more from us where from
or the stylist wants to know
exactly what looks good
it is always so quick
so you are now in certain
areas because  not delivery logistics so I
can understand it well but fashion is
also difficult than I mean that not
like that  s people say how is it about the
camera i always had the latest
magazines in front of it and then you understand in
the end it's also like
people who have to play a role
and have to recognize
what's hot right now
and what can you do with the types
because of his height, he does
n't know, hair color or anything else,
so the socialist is
sitting down there, too, then read a
fashion magazine, or just bring it with you,
and where does it come from, so check
it in the job interview according to the
motto,
so first of all, that's it  Important for
us it's not so much about trends
, it's about you above all we
want to understand exactly who you are you want
to be and what makes you special because
it's about this personalization
understanding exactly what your
body shape is  what goes with which
cuts go with your body shape i have, for
example, on my upper body that means
i always have to make sure that my the waistband
of  my pants are relatively high
to give an example or what are
your colors i did
n't know for a long time what kind of red
i can wear because i have
blonde red hair and now my
stylist has chosen a bright pink suit for me
and  i thought you put it on right away
and it was just really awesome and
i felt good so that
these are the things that are interesting
and then on the subject of style or to say
which style you want to
have it's more about that  you and what
you want to express but we
knew about it he is so it's
the instance that he then says okay here
look at the pink suit now it will go
well with her so it's like that
people who moderated it then  or
where exactly do we come from and that is
the next point so one thing is my
focus is on you as a customer and the
understanding of who you are and
our stylists are experts d  you
studied fashion who worked in the fashion trade for a long time
, who can simply empathize with
people
and then not to say what's trending right
now in berlin-mitte recommend for you
, but really
feel into it and have the expertise for you
there too  things to recommend that you
don't commercial full women it's
both exactly but half and half he's
more women than men to be fair yes ok
yes then from time to time does the
six actors really make sense
recommend we see it every
day on  feedback from customers how good
it is, of
course, that’s how they’re measured, so
customer satisfaction is
crucial, as we say, at the
performance of each individual stylist, just
look a little bit in the fashion scene
now, so if
not FC Bayern  fashion week or
any other things are you there that
plays a role don't you have your
own fashion network either  or is
that more business for you
and that would this time we have
a team that is on the road to all these trade fairs
and then
find out the coolest new brands if now
for women too, for example, many really
cool scandinavian bands the 100 per
the german woman still  don't know and
can just get to know them through us
i am myself i find fashion
totally exciting and it's a lot of fun for me
so at least now reporters very
fashionably divided one is yes my
top is still a men's top by the
way i'm only slowly moving
into women's but
it's my color i know that from
my journalist
and
whether you do fashion shows
yourself or i am enthusiastic about outfit
ruf especially for the customer and
how we can interact with customers, so to speak
, how we
can further expand the model and the
technology  behind how many active
key witnesses
we have hundreds of thousands of active
customers
and that's saying  a total of a
million customers who have already tried out
what can then most of them so
what is it then simply that it didn’t
work or that it works like that
we actually have to we should
stay there so what what what is
reason at all well the main reason is  if
we
just don't do a good job,
so to speak, and and don't recommend the right thing
or and that was
a big reason for him in the past that
customers have said i would also like to
shop differently with you, i.e. if i
just want a certain category
but not just
i would like to buy roses from you in the
app and be able to order it that way and
that's one of the reasons why we're
offering it now ok then of course it's also
on the web advertising brochures to land and in
the big ones yes although we have a completely
different approach  because we do
n't start with the trending range,
we really start with you and
with us you can i  in the app you don't
see our entire range either,
you really only see the selection that
fits philipp is okay then i can buy which pair of pants I
want to buy directly
then i have the limited selection
can buy them directly but you
don't have to look at everything, so to speak
and rummage through to page 10 of the catalogue
, but you are just
shown the things that fit your
body and your style exactly,
because it says so when you go shopping,
but logically you know what
is coming right now, which
is becoming a bit
more effective in many poles  absolutely like shopping as the normal
online shop, so of course we have
very deep data about every
customer, around 200 data points when you
start with us and then of course with
every transaction with every online
rating what you give us
we learn more from the article we have to
example if that's our fashion
kids that means you can just li in the app
nks or to the right whether you think
it's good to share or not
and we learn about that and so
we have a lot of data and that also
helps us when shopping but
also what we now have with
our
exclusive bands that means we
just have  found
that we know the customer so well that
there are certain
things in the range that aren’t even covered
by the brands because the brands are
still i know what’s missing what the
products don’t see that so
we’re clarifying that here  for example that
you look at everything but in sterling forces
what we are going to post there it
's a peculiar okay a tick and
from that it's just about the details
that are important so how easy
is it to do is there at the
button panel again in detail what people think is
cool how is the cut of the
whole thing yes and it runs the whole game
it out in the end so now you make like
100 million around there  s you said it
's profitable probably
also needs to be financed out so now no longer
listed or something like that
makes heard so 50 60 million you can
read it flowed in
yes what's important for the next few years it
's also on the stock exchange or what somehow
comes at some point then is  it's fixed and
buy or does he come to alando take over
but also so how's it going so
we're now focused
on letting petri grow profitably and
so i think we currently have super cool
growth opportunities, so women for
women what we just brought
live is a big one  growth lever that
we are now tackling the second is the topic of
internationalization
as I said a market like france
works very well for us but there
are also other international
european markets how exciting are whether
that is eastern europe whether the uk is whether that is
southern europe and the third is ours
service even further and the
customer more poss  to give opportunities so
we have just seen that we have supported the
algorithms that previously
supported the stylist ladies or the
stylist in the selection that they
are now so good that we can also
display them directly to the customer these recommendations about it and that
opens up completely new ones  opportunities
to design our product and to give the customer a
lot more flexibility and these
are, so to speak, the internationalization target group
and in service
experts are the three
growth levers we are working on right now okay okay and
then what kind of growth do you need at the
moment, around 20 to 30 percent growth  but
that would be required i now have
the next one to create thank you david
habel on and then endgame
but you don't know yet exactly whether
i might have gotten on the stock market myself
whether it'll be another ten years
so it's my personal interest so to speak
and my  personal
motivation is simply the idea of
d  this is this personalization
and ultimately helping people
to express themselves through fashion
and also
to convey a certain self-confidence that
i just want to make this idea as
big as possible and what exactly the
steps will be and what
the path is, we will  see okay
but if we somehow
often people here said because
after a few months a few years I have already become
very very wealthy so the
question is can you just do it with it
or is it now a millionaire more and more
families it is an open question whether it will work
then
professional success is validated again in the same way
but for you it’s in your head or long ago
actually also economic
dependency or that’s for you so an
additional aspect
obviously also plays a role but
for me I mean I’ve been doing it
for almost 10 years now  and my motivation to get
up every day and put on an
outfit full throttle  in the end, working is
the impact and the difference
we can have for customers and what would it be like
just getting feedback from these
customers
and the second thing is also what i can learn
, so i said it earlier,
this this this journey from female founders to
sio  i have unbelievably great people
in the team from whom i
learned i
founded my trier yes i had
managed people before but of course i
had never had such a
responsibility and i learned all that
from them and yes  so
this this learning journey
that for me is one of the aids orphan
aspects if it has stayed better
and because there was never a share or options
or anything like that so early on it is
okay means it could even
theoretically have been more attractive for
them  to stay there for ten years is to
take full growth with you when
that was honestly not a
question for me and that was it so i
got it  also made it clear from the start
that i'm there to start my own company at some point
yes and accordingly and
tell
me you'll get a lot of offers now it feels like the whole economy is looking for women with cool stories now you've
built up a company like that which isn't that
scary in terms of turnover  and so
then I will probably act
as an advisory board member for the other companies
it was attractive as minister publisher
it will also be like
that that's definitely an issue yes definitely so it
hasn't increased over the last few
years but because of focus yes but
I could imagine presley could I
imagine you can leave it open it
's okay okay yeah cool so I'm
very excited I'll have
you ever go out there my last
trip was a few years ago
that's why I didn't have that with these
intermediate steps at the time
experienced that you somehow so to say
I always had the box because you yes, I
have a conscience  bt can say so much about then
that I
give away the tempo and then
but
okay well I well I always have black and blue white
just simple it's not really either
then maybe it'll be easy for me
I'll try it out
many many thanks for you  came
and of course
because we continue to follow the journey and
keep an
eye on the inventory of the German
start-up scene from the beginning not from the
beginning long years of battery
and I think that's the most well-known
companies founded 55 women and  led
then there is still cheating she still
looks like that makes sense of the peer group
you mean exactly to the phase and also
just such a women management team
so i would say the
berlin founders that is such a network
also a really great network where
we mutually  support and
exchange but that's already
torture the pension finances otherwise
but there are also other companies like that
ha  have you been doing this for as long as you
so long as now these that
have gone on a journey because most of them are
out now so verena faißt there is
out of their company lea is out with
you everything is
right you have quite a lot of breath
how is it  explain
like that i'm just
not
okay so we're watching the weather
back in the data is all good
[music]